[Music]
pastor mark the question is what is the
falling away what is the falling away
the falling away is mentioned in the
book of thessalonians and let me just
read it to you uh in here in the book of
thessalonians we're looking here at
the apostle paul's writings
in um we'll go to second thessalonians
chapter two verse one to four and uh
we're going to look here at just exactly
what the scripture says you know it's
always important to go directly to the
bible and when you go directly to the
bible you find the answers from from
scripture you don't have to worry about
human answers and you don't have to
worry about what uh human beings say but
the question about the falling away is
really really a good question and um
it uh
says here in second thessalonians
chapter two verse one to four now we
beseech you brethren by the coming of
our lord by our gathering together to
him that's when christ comes that you be
not soon shaken in mind or troubled
neither by spirit nor by word nor by
letter as from us that the day of the
lord is at hand so paul was saying to
them that um
don't think based on first thessalonians
that he has written previously that the
coming of christ is going to take place
right away that's he's writing to the
church at thessalonica in the first
century let no man deceive you by any
means he says don't be deceived that day
that is coming of christ shall not come
except there be a falling away first
that the man of sin be revealed in the
son of perdition the falling away is a
departure from biblical truth
and it says that the man of sin is going
to exalt himself above all that is
called god or that's worshiped so he as
god sits in the temple of god showing
himself that he is god so in other words
what the bible is saying is that to be
this falling away that the antichrist
power
would
manifest himself
and he would institute
human traditions human ideas human
opinions and that the falling away is a
flowing away of truth from the scripture
that's why jesus said in john 17 verse
17 sanctify them through thy word thy
word is truth that's why the bible says
in acts in isaiah 8 20 to the law into
the testimony if they speak not
according to this word it's because
there's no light in them so there may be
power in a movement there may be some
truth but the bible says to the law and
to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there's no light
light is what you follow so the falling
away is a departure from the light of
truth of god's word it's a drifting from
god's commandments and it's the
institution of the commandments of men
for the commandments of god
all right pastor mark thank you for that
answer hey everybody matt gray here
media director for hopeless365 don't go
yet make sure that you subscribe and
click the bell so you get notified of
the next video in this series and i
think you should check out these other
videos over there i think you'll like
those as well see ya